well joining me is former England
cricket Legends Jeffrey boycott the
conservative peer Lord Marlin who was at
Lords yesterday and the Australian
cricket commentator Melinda Farrell I'm
also joined in the studio by the
associates of the Daily Mirror Kevin
McGuire okay well this is a a great
lineup to have Sir Jeffrey I read your
uh brilliant column in the telegraph
Daily Telegraph earlier today uh in
which you uh demanded an apology from
the Australian team tell me why you
think that is uh in order
well I didn't demand anything I said it
would be waste look if he doesn't know
the rights between playing
right to the letter of the law
and what is good for the spirit of the
game then I don't know I can't teach him
um in 1932-33 when the body line was
play it was Australia that first started
it by sending a telegram that didn't
like Bodyline which was within the rules
by Jardine and his team beating them and
they sent the telegram to the MCC saying
this is not Cricket it's not in the
spirit of the game so those in Australia
that were siding with the Australians so
playing to the letter of the the Lord as
it were should they go back to
1932-33 and also their Captain told Plum
Warner who was the manager of the MCC
team and went into the dressing room and
one and Warner got told by the captain
of Australia there are two teams out
there and only one is playing Cricket so
they didn't like the way it was being
played within the rules and they went
further than that
the after the series was lost by
Australia they got England pressured
them to change the rules of the game the
laws of the game and they also said when
we're due to come to you in 1938 to play
a tour of England if you're going to
bold body line we're not coming and MCC
said okay we won't and they came on the
tour so they were the first to start
this about the standards in the game and
if Pat Cummins and his team don't know
what standards are then I can't teach
him and if you want to win at any cost
that's not good and Jeffrey Jeffries
known for gamesmanship underhand things
Jeffrey for those who are not massive
Cricket fans but are aware of this
because all over the front pages and the
TV news in your estimation what happened
here that was wrong
well first of all Johnny bestow was
dogzy Daft is a brush for wandering
around because usually you have to wait
for the Umpire the bowler's end to call
over that means the ball is dead you
cannot be out then so he should have
waited for the Empire to call over at
the end of the over or if he wanted to
go down the pitch and tap down the pitch
which happens often or talk to his mate
the captain it looks should look behind
it carries it and sort of is it okay
Carrie shoot would have nodded and off
he went that's the only way you do it it
didn't do anything else so he was a bit
Daft and dozy Kerry did what you do
instinctively emotionally in the middle
of a game
but I've been reflected on it Cummins
him the team should have said hang on
hang on a minute and if they couldn't do
it then they can do it now they can
think hang on we win the game brilliant
Cricket played by both teams lots of
wonderful entertainment for everybody
you've spoiled it at the end you've
tarnished it you've tarnished your good
name give tarnish Cricket put your hand
up say hey in the Heat of the Moment We
got it wrong we'd like to say we
foulsomely apologized it won't happen
again that sort of thing shake hands
when you meet Ben Stills move on
everybody be much happier because
there's nothing wrong with anybody me
included we make mistakes with human
beings put your under when you made a
mistake and say hey I got it wrong I'm
sorry
okay do it again Melinda Farrell you've
heard that from the great Sir Jeffrey uh
one of the all-time great England
cricketers and Ash's Legends who
actually in his column also told a
fascinating story which I'll just
quickly paraphrase where he was playing
against the Australians and he handled
the ball and the wiki keeper Wally Grau
actually said to him don't do that son
rather than appeal and get him out which
was an extraordinary Act of
sportsmanship that's how it used to be
Melinda you cannot be happy
with what you witnessed there that's not
how Australia would feel happy winning
an ashes game is it
I think the the players feel quite okay
about how that's happened I actually
agree with with stuff some stuff that
you've said appears in there and with uh
Sir Jeffrey as well
look you there's there's so much water
Valerie that comes in into things like
this when it happens and I think because
passions are so inflamed people often
tend to see things through the prism of
which team it's happened to whether it's
their team or the opposition whether
they like that team and also whether
they win or lose I think it's a great
shame that this has overshadowed uh Ben
Stokes playing the most magnificent
Innings I've seen in place since the
last magnificent ridiculous Innings that
he played and maybe that wouldn't have
happened if it wasn't for this incident
because it fired him up to do something
incredible
I I think the spirit of Prickett when
people start talking about that it can
be very nebulous it can mean different
things to different people you ask
people and it's very hard to Define
because it doesn't really Define
anything much in there apart
I thought about this I've heard people
say this I think you it's undefinable
there's no if it was definable it would
be written in the laws right the spirit
of cricket though comes when everybody
basically feels in their bones there's
something unfair has happened I think
and I don't think you can possibly look
at bearsto who you see scraping his boot
inside the crease which is what batsman
do either with their boot or their bat
to denote it's the end of an over and
then to casually walk down the speech
was captured every Australian player
knew what he was doing they all knew he
wasn't trying to get an advantage so to
run him out in the way that they did to
stump him as they tried to describe it I
don't think it's a stumping but whatever
you want to call it but for Pat Cummings
he's Mr Nice Guy uh after we had the
whole incident of course around
sandpaper gate where all hell broke
loose in Australia and many Australians
were as outraged as we were by sandpaper
gay I'm just surprised that Pat Cummings
who seems a pretty decent guy didn't do
the right thing and actually make the
world feel good about Australia and
sportsmanship
well I I think that's that's up to Pat
Cummins as far as where he thinks that
sort of dismissal Falls I do know that a
lot of people who have been contacting
me say that you see this a lot in it
it's instinctive from The Keeper so I
don't think anyone has an issue with it
actually being out and as so Jeffrey
said it was a mistake by besto so he's
made a mistake Kerry hasn't done the
right the wrong thing and it's something
that that a lot of Keepers do do
instinctively they had noticed he was
wandering out of his crease and bestow
had done something similar uh a couple
of them the person I blame the person I
blame is the captain because I've seen
Ms dhoni the former Indian captain in a
similar situation actually reversed the
decision withdraw the appeal this has
been done before and those captains by
the way when they do that kind of thing
they get revered forever in cricket
folklore for being Sportsman and that's
why again I'm surprised I want to bring
in Lord Marlin well Marlon I saw you on
day one of the laws test we were
enabling boxes enjoying the the uh the
match and then you were there yesterday
I think it was a very different
atmosphere what did you make of what
happened there and also what did you
make of what happened I was there I'm
sorry yeah I was there for three days
not yesterday but right okay so you were
there the first three days so but I
presume you watched what was going on
yesterday
um oh yeah what did you make of what
happened on the pitch and also what did
you make of what happened in the laws
Pavilion the scenes of which I I gotta
say I found the spectacle of MCC members
chanting cheat cheat was pretty
disgusting actually and I'm glad
action's been taken against him but it
showed the measure of the anger in the
ground uh what did you make of what
happened and the Fallout
well I totally agree with you which
often I do peers uh it was very
unsporting I think you're completely
right that the captain should have on
field made the decision look you know uh
well done Kerry but we're not going to
uh call you out go back to your crease
which would have been the sportsman-like
thing to do
of course in defensive Cummings it's a
very instant decision you've got to make
you don't have the opportunity of time
you have to make a decision at the
moment but I think the thing is defined
by Ben Stokes in a way and what he said
afterwards which and I think Ben Stokes
is one of the great sporting Heroes that
he said he wouldn't have done it himself
and that for me is good enough of course
uh the Rivalry you know it is just
another twist isn't it in the Australia
England or the ashes series is not an
attractive one they'll get booed every
time they walk out on the ground if
that's what they want that's fine I
totally agree with you about the
behavior in the long room it's very
unseemly but it you know Cricket has
moved on from this very polite life that
you have at the MCC to a contrast of
Edwardson where I was also where there's
this little rowdy crowd really exciting
atmosphere
and so you know it's where's that
balance and of course the long room for
that point of view is sacrifice act but
it could be argued if you're out in the
crowd you'd have done that
Kevin Maguire instead of listening to
all this I mean are we as many
Australians claim you know Melinda
reference to what a battery there are
episodes in England's cricketing pass
which wouldn't shine up very well if you
put the spirit of qriket test to it
um I was at a game at the oval in 2008
when one of the New Zealand players ran
into our bowler a complete accident he
fell over and was run out and we we
didn't withdraw the appeal I thought
that was completely wrong so I think I'd
be consistent I don't like any of that
stuff what do you make of it yeah I
think of Ollie Pope and New Zealand in
the slips uh is an lbw appeal the uh
kiwi batsman wanders out takes the uh
stumps off and bastos all you know high
fives and uh and great fun I think we're
in danger in England now we're in
England the difference there is though
yeah nobody thought the play was dead no
play was still out well I think the
batsman did I don't think they thought
it was going to be an appeal it was what
he was waiting for for the Umpire and
the uh the play would get deemed still
like but I think we're we're in danger
you're assigning bad losers and whining
whinging Palms look it was in the rules
this is the ashes you know fiercest
sporting contest are you an Aussie
Skipper going to give that away Ben
Stiller actually if you're I would say
if you're I would say if your country
has been through sandpaper gate yeah or
the captain and Vice Captain both had to
resign their jobs in tears on television
this was a brilliant opportunity for
pack companies who by all accounts is a
good guy a great opportunity for him to
reset the profile of the Australian
cricket team on the global stage by
doing something that he may not
obviously interview wanted to but felt
actually was the right thing but it's
not sunpith some people get was clear
we'll have a cheater cheating this is
not cheating it was willing the rules
the umpires upheld it what happened to
the umpire's decision as final they'll
players get gave a man now I agree with
Lord Marlin though the behavior of the
uh who rear Henry's the uh Posh
Hooligans in the Pavilion look they've
got privileged access to the players
yeah it doesn't mean you have to you
know smother them with kisses uh I
didn't like that at all I thought that
was behave like that at all and also
chanting cheat cheat when they haven't
actually cheated I thought that was
completely wrong uh so Jeffrey let me
come back to you for the final word I
always like to do that uh the next test
match starts in a few days aheadingly
your neck of the woods your great ground
where you broke so many records this I
would imagine is going to fire up the
England team like nothing else could
possibly do it will also fire up that
Yorkshire crowd like nothing else could
possibly it's gonna be like him let me
tell you
they'll be ready for him no doubt at all
what do you have to remember
I don't like Kevin's point because if
everybody played to the rules absolute
letter of the rules what would happen
now is England and its players will be
looking to get their own back
so then we tip for that all the time
looking for gamesmanship underhand
things and the tricky as we know it
would disintegrate because players would
be looking to score a point get their
own back is that what we want to Cricket
no we want the tricky this and teams
just looking to get their own back
gamesmanship underhand things dirty
things you know I don't want that at
Cricket this the cricket played by these
two teams are fairly equal we've been
Daft enough to do stupid things at the
moments when we're winning the match and
we should have been doing it not too nil
down we're equal to them we could easily
beat them but we're doing death things
but that's not the point it's not about
the winning losing it it's about the
standards of the game and when you're
talking about the members of MCC they're
not all hooray henries with lots of
money and gone to private schools it was
an emotional moment I agree it was
unsavory and they deserve essential but
I don't think the diesel does have to
lose their membership at all it's an
emotional moment it certainly wasn't as
bad as what the Australian Captain
didn't do and I agree with you peers he
had a moment there an opportunity to
square things with the world because
what they did in Cape Town was pure and
simply cheating and that's why they got
chanting in the long room not just for
that incident it's for what they did in
Cape Town was that wasn't against the
spirit of the game that's pure and
simple cheating
so Jeffrey as always magnificent to
watch you budding uh thank you very much
today for joining me and Melinda thank
you be under pounding and we're going to
win the ashes
I think we are going to win the ashes
3-2 I think the so far as to Victory um
Linda I want to thank you especially
because uh we couldn't get any current
or ex-australian player or any other
Australian media figure to come on and
you bravely came over the parapet to
defend your country everyone's talking
about cricket and the ashes exactly by
the time when everyone says Cricket's
dying let's let's uh just essentially
certainly isn't dying now uh great to
see you lamanna great to see you Kevin
thank you very much indeed